tanti ragazzi in benvenuti a questo
video sono pari che io ci siamo su un
normalissimo episodio di happy with
perché porca vacca l'ultimo episodio è
stato un pò veloce
la gita with non so un primo che mi
ispira che ci prendi l'arpione questi
sono bellissimi prendi l'azione è
incastrata nel soffitto non sarà
riuscito cedeva in castello nel soffitto
e poi cadere i giovani impossibile ma no
eh va beh non ci credo sono ritornato
nei cannoni uomo vero ci posso credere
no non ha vinto di nuovo da porco il
demonio ma noi veramente è stata è stato
un mix di sfighe ci posso credere una
sfiga l'andata la spiga ritorno eccoci e
l'omesso dondolati di più ecco
te la devi per forza spaccare la testa
se non sei contento avevo capito mind
the difference come hai scritto
differenza che approvammo se che vedevo
di cliccare sulle differenti quel gioco
della settimana enigmistica
esatto allora credo che le differenze
siano allora quella nuvola e blu nonno
ciak qua e un alcolizzato di lana qua
c'è la targa rotta prova anche un
piccione la cesta il coso e di ai
capelli neri il fanale 92
porca vacca non è facile a qua c'è il
marciapiedi lungo no qua ce la faccia
per l'umano che cacchio è c'è un video
né sfalsato qualche un bidone spanò c'è
una maniglia nemmeno nemmeno ne manca
solo uno spreco non lo vedo non c'è
anche nella gamba ha la gamba di nunno
ciacca una gamba in più l'ha proprio
vista
che figata e un make concept per un
livello di fds strano telefono tutti
cagare quindi non so aspettare niente
non faccio pagare
purtroppo fox pitt molto più speed zio
largo il saltare
le radio bravissimo e vabbè come fa ma
penso facile rovini è impossibile
ragazzetto livello impossibile porca
vacca
ma dai ma dai un'ora e mezza per poi ma
dai nuclei e rossetti non era lì non si
possono saltare gli ostacoli studi è
veramente impossibile ragazzi per non so
neanche come cosa ti aspetti che io
faccia ma non lo salta non ci arriva lo
capisci che non ci si può arrivare
troppo in alto il cubo non lo possa fare
non si può saltare il cubo e paga lo
ricordo non un sacco di umiltà non ci
arrivo ma guarda non lo può non lo molla
ragazzi non l'ho ma guarda pravaccio
semplice adesso sì però se tu salti non
lo molla che va avanti lui e quindi mi
fa sbattere uguale non serve a niente
posso farlo tutto il tempo ma non si può
non si può vincere il suo livello
tiracchia volti tirati un pezzo del mio
corpo ha vinto va bene chi lo dava gates
ha perso un timpano ho perso l'altro
timpano non sto più sentendo neanche
quello che di porco demonio ma stai
zitto
io sono lui ok ma quanto è brutto molto
bene strutto chiaro tutto a posto va
bene ho letto yeah non ho già più un
braccio video già perso quando sul rock
singh perdete un braccio avete
praticamente perso perché lui un braccio
solo non lo può usare gli si stacca se
fai il giro lì si stacca quindi
teoricamente ne devo usare due per forza
far questo è un rock no incubo cubo
swing molto bene allora loro via piano
piano piano piano salto giusto salto
giusto tanto giusto questo è un salto
giusto salto più giusto
va benissimo uguale grave with free
tekken 6 è uno solo freccia direzionale
invece giusto mi piace entrare il
cannone sarebbe stato impossibile
[Musica]
let's golf
molto bene la vittoria c'è imposti per
99 per cento fammi vedere la madonna
stai calmo però non sarà fuori sono
arrivato anche parte tipo così niente ma
amico mio niente male se riuscissi a
saltare proprio storto madonna che bravo
un po meno morto però ok tutto
tranquillo visite fosse tutto buono se
cado giù e che già faccio se fossi
caduto dalla parte giusta però va bene
l'ex che ho vinto in una maniera
incredibile vi prego guardatelo
praticamente mi ha spazzato via le bombe
la la cosa con la palla di cannone due
c'erano più che altro non è anche dopo
una notte non è toccato niente abbiamo
vinto per sbaglio perché no in realtà
non ho vinto prole varas uno stress
i quattro fisico 66 a lei schiera a
bambù la sua dato sono state contate per
tutti cioè se sbagli una volta hai perso
chi di voi già sbagliato tory che hanno
già perso ma forse no forse ce le giuste
by minasi l'ho preso e fatto sono caduti
due tutto regolare windows 10 vyrus
water park
oddio dove devo ai forgot mapping sin
option e cosa faccio
menu menù era il tasto menù era un tasto
over pietro pozzolane passo però non
funziona e mi fai fare qualcosa o non mi
fai fare qualcosa 1342 perfetto è pierre
crobe henry dmin.it robot è il top 3 che
hanno fatto il mio livello 9 secondi 11
e 12 secondi alla chissenefrega oggi è
il 20 di gennaio mazzo pone tempo è
passato sia briamo google
clicca qua per ricevere iphone 11 pro il
100 per cento no vyrus cricca cui
cliccato quindi dire ho trovato virus ma
windows defender antivirus bond cioè
details
critical error ok quickscan oddio hai
fatto benissimo l'anno fatto troppo bene
porca vacca quickscan una sega ci sta
mettendo due ore sono dio va bene iphone
11 pro punto ex e maschi e come il gioco
che avevo fatto ve lo ricordate
bisognava sconfiggere il boss però stai
calmo che se un virus
però il tuo pc erba beh l'ho finito
vabbè ha fatto benissimo è stato geniale
bellissimo deschain tre master ed
facciamo l'ultimo fatto bene
[Musica]
rifacciamo l'ultimo fatto bene allora
aspetta che mi lancio il lancio meglio
non mi lancio meglio se mi lancio meglio
forse salto non so saltare porco demonio
è veramente difficile ragazzi però
aspetta che ho capito quanto lanciare in
mezzo e fin qua slow down giampà game e
non ci arrivo mi devo tirare su ma non
ci arriva ex cacchio tirare sparami su
in alto va bene tutt'altro c'è un babbo
natale che all'inizio parte ball
fortissimo mag sono morto sono morto
adattato quello non era il finale era
questo il finale non ce la farò mai
c'è un impulsivo di un'altra generazione
proprio è un imposti pò del 2020 verso
ragazzi fatto benissimo
no ragazzi finché non ci riesco in un
uomo ne vado è difficilissima e un
livello fatto benissimo e proprio è
proprio un tipo di imposti con loro solo
che è molto difficile però ci prova
ragazzi ok ti prego porca vacca devo
saltare oltre no ma ragazza
impossibile c'è chi l'ha inventato sto
livello è veramente assurdo aspetta che
ci fa fare un salto a gente
bello questo è partita bene ragazzi è
partita bene è partita bene è partita
bene
[Musica]